right
welcome to cabinet everybody my
apologies for slight delay while we
worked out how to do the webcast so
without further ado apologies for
absence punches received from councillor
thermal and from councillor Barker Thank
You disclosures of interest any
disclosures of interest in items on the
agenda I'll take that as a resounding no
minutes from thermos on the minutes of
the meeting yes leader and minute two to
eight an amendment to the minutes
pleased and this is to show that the
supplementary paper which was circulated
at the meeting on the 30th of July
stated under paragraph 1 point 2 that
the proposal is to purchase up to six
properties and the cabinet minutes
reflected that it was three properties
so to amend that to 6 so amend that to
be to 6 and if I remember correctly that
was within the financial limit specified
in the paper do we pause the meeting
while that is checked or do we carry on
in that case can I just have everyone's
agreement to the minutes us revise
please agreed that case I will declare a
short recess well we'll get the loop
fixed assuming we can
can you hear that note right
okay meeting resumed so mutters item
four mutters to be referred to the
counsel non I am now going to reorder
the agenda slightly because we have
people to speak on item eight brailles
and winter term Neighborhood Development
Plan so we will now take item eight
reales and wind it in neighborhood
development plan councillor Pemberton
thank thank you leader so it is going to
be one of those I'm gonna go old school
and refer to the papers I've just so we
have the brows and Winterton
Neighborhood Development Plan so we're
at the the pre submission consultation
response stage whereby we as an
authority have made a number of comments
to the pre-consultation documents and
we're looking for for endorsements and
for those to be then submitted to the
Parish Council as this Authority's
formal response to the pre submission
consultation and on the basis that we
have some speakers and it will allow me
the opportunity to clear myself up I'm
going to I'm going to invite the
speakers from brows and winter to
Neighborhood Development Plan group to
address the meeting yes I'm Peter Jordan
why should you be in speaking and good
afternoon everyone say my name's Peter
Jordan I'm the vice chairman of the
group I'd like to update the cabinet on
the progress that the Browns
neighborhood plan has made as a result
of the regulation 14 consultation
carried out between the 13th of June
2018 and a 25th of July 2018 we held two
open days in the parish to allow local
feedback the feedback we got was very
positive and supportive we then had 12
responses from the consultation bodies
again positive and we have incorporated
their feedback into the new draft with
regard to the SDC feedback discovered 51
comments 32 of these comments were
appearance and wording related and we
have incorporated almost all of them
into our new draft plan the remaining 19
were policy specific we have
incorporated many of these into the new
draft and on meeting with two members of
the SDC Planning Group on Thursday
morning this week to better understand a
few of the comments and see how we can
incorporate them into the plan we are
waiting our final ACA report the early
draft that went out for consultation was
again very positive and supportive and
our objective is to put the plan forward
for submission as soon as is practicable
thank you thank you very much and it's
heartening to hear you've been so
proactive about setting up a discussion
with officers to pick up the policy
points as ever with all of these they
they're gone through with a fine-tooth
comb if it fits up and dot's the eyes
across as the t's which is the right
thing because these are formal documents
and if they're not picked up there
somebody will pick it up and we wouldn't
want anybody wanted to challenge your
plan for a common being in the wrong
place so it can't that's that so I think
that sounds like good progress there the
the plan group meeting on Thursday
should then be in a position to move so
on that basis I think that actually the
recommendation is to some degree almost
it's almost been agreed for us by the
actions of the the the positive and
quick actions of the group so really
looking that the schedule of comments be
endorsed and submitted that that's
already in train so I think hopefully I
can get members
cabinet just to agree the recommendation
on the cabinet do we agree the
recommendation thank you thank you
can I just congratulate the whole
councils chairman it's great to see
coming in here at this critical stage
and I think brailles need to be
congratulated for taking the step to
come to cabinet present thank you for
your kind comments councillor kettle I
think you are absolutely right it is
good to say that an awful lot of effort
does go into these neighborhood
development plans so now we will
continue to item 9 which is Loxley
Neighborhood Development Plan because I
believe councillor Adama wishes to speak
on this later councillor Pemberton first
thank thank you once again the Loxley
Neighborhood Development Plan is at its
pre submission consultation stage and
our officers have made a number of
comments at appendix one I think I'll
probably pause at that point and and let
cancer O'Donnell
make any representations so anything
that she wishes to thank you thank you
it was really just a feedback had the
Parish Council we're feeling about the
progression thus far they're relieved
we've got to this stage councillor
Pemberton because their initial
discussions started back in 2015 they've
said whilst they've been keen to keep it
resident led it's proved tricky to keep
to and get the necessary leadership with
aggression there's been a high level of
engagement within the actual village and
there's a high return rate for the
surveys they sent to the residence as
Loxley such a small village there they
are limited in their capacity to deliver
the plan they feel and given the small
community the topography and
environmental designations there are
actually limited sites they could look
at which are not compromised in one way
or another and also local politics have
made it really tricky because most
people have a site close to them however
they have gone to consultation on as
many sites as they could
as a pouch council they've sat down
narrowed down the information and
analyzed the feedback they discussed it
with the consultants they are looking
forward to the District Council's
detailed feedback and guidance which
once they have it they'll again discuss
with their consultants Thank You
councillor O'Donnell I think first of
all I think around this table and in
this authority I think we all recognize
the challenges that that some of the
smaller settlements have in terms of
having the capacity to deliver on these
plans the plans are important and I
think clearly in Loxley people both in
terms of the of the parish council
itself and the right and the residents
understand the value I think just
looking across to officers I think if we
you know we already provide a level of
support to to those who are looking to
put a neighborhood development plan
together and I think we'll just pick up
on those comments and if there's any
additional level of support that we can
give and give them what you've you just
flagged their roads as they you know
there were only a few people there to be
taking up the strain we will clearly do
what we can it's a good piece of work
that's been done you know III knowledge
that it's been since 2015 but partly
that's a function I think as you say of
having the bandwidth to drive it forward
it is a good piece of work I think we've
got some positive comments and I'm sure
that working together with Loxley that
we can get them to a point where they're
able to get out to to referendum and get
the thing signed off so please pass on
my thanks and the thanks of cabinet and
council generally to work it to your to
your pursing Loxley for me it's really
just looking at the recommendation which
again our responses are in Appendix 1
happy to go through anything but if if
not put the recommendation that they be
endorsed and submitted as our formal
response cabinet are we happy with the
recommendations
good thank you we will now move back to
item 5 which is the CCTV maintenance
contract which is down to me as
councillor Harris was on holiday when
this was produced so it's very simple
actually it's about the renewal of the
current CCTV maintenance contract and
the reason this is here is because it's
a cumulative value of successive CCTV
maintenance contracts which have come to
a total of two hundred and twelve
thousand four hundred and seventy-seven
pounds approximately so approval is
required for contract exemption by the
cabinet the reality is that this will be
the last time this contract will come to
the council because as you are all aware
we are updating the control room and
that will mean the start of a whole new
contract series from that control room
being updated so this really is I think
a matter of some routine so given the
recommendation is that the contract
exemptions for the renewal of current
CCT then CCTV management maintenance
contract be approved can I have your
approval please cabinet good thank you
I'm sorry counselor kettle if you recall
some months if not possibly a year ago
when you portfolio holder the CCTV
I brought your attention some villages
have their own CCTV schemes or network
setup it has to be or should there be an
approach by this council to those
villages to see if given that we have
this contract in place that is something
that we should be progressing can
although technically this is not
pertinent to this particular paper
at the moment there is a lot of work
going on scoping out exactly what needs
to be done the issues you raised have
definitely not been forgotten and will
form part of that scoping exercise as
you may appreciate it's actually quite
complex to scope out what needs to be
done and the intention is to put the
control room in first and then roll out
the cameras across the district if what
you raised has definitely not been
forgotten Council okay thank you some
item six stratford-upon-avon market for
in terms of reference counselor house
Thank You leader yes this comfortable
cabinet for approval to get some minor
adjustments made to the terms of
reference the marking market forum
oversees the the running of the market
so it includes representatives from the
district and Town Council's contractor
and from strap forward at recent
meetings however it's been difficult at
times to keep the meeting warrant so
what has been suggested is that we
increase the number of representatives
from two to three from the town council
and from the district council so it's
quite a simple change and the
recommendation is that the revised
stratford-upon-avon market forum terms
of reference are agreed Thank You leader
any discussion any questions in that
case can I have your agreement to the
recommendation on page 13 thank you so
the item seven the member development
working group work program as councillor
was Phil will is on holiday I will take
this the work program is actually
contained here the one item I would draw
people's attention to is may 20 19
progress on induction program
just a comment that given the likely
given the likely number of new
counselors next year it is vitally
important that that induction program is
very thorough and is actually
implemented extremely swiftly I think
that is probably the main point coming
out of the word program so without are
there any questions any comments which I
will do my best to answer in that case
can I have the recommendation that the
word program has presented be approved
thank you
item no sorry we've done item eight
we're done item nine so we are now on
item ten page 49 which is purpose-built
temporary accommodation scheme for
stratford-upon-avon counselor pending
once again thank you leader as members
will know and this castle has relied on
the use of B&B over a number of years to
discharge its its statutory duty and
we've been trying to reduce and
eliminate as far as possible the use of
B&B and we've been using a very an umber
of various different strategies
including leasing temporary
accommodation we have considered
previously the question of a
purpose-built facility but we have been
putting in place a number of strategies
so far this year and the recommendation
is that in essence we should allow those
to bed down for a period of a few months
until the new year before making a final
decision on a purpose-built
accommodation scheme rather early in the
new financial year I should just be just
clarify that which is the recommendation
I see that councillor Morse would
perhaps like to address cabinet and it
might be as well
to hear what counselor Morse has got to
say in the first instance before any
further discussion you'll see later in
the papers in the first four months of
this year we were a hundred and seventy
seven thousand pounds over budget of
course with this when we come to the
second eight months fear but forecasting
will be twenty seven thousand pounds
under budget so we're saying that will
only be a hundred and fifty thousand
over budget for the whole year
even though seventy-seven present time
chairman the bed and breakfast budget is
getting out of hand
you may have seen from the figures I'll
just lead out the last four years bed
and breakfast costs if I may and this is
after the council's reclaim thought he
can or on housing benefit fourteen
fifteen nineteen thirty foot fourteen
fifty five thousand pounds fifteen
sixteen thirty seven thousand pounds
sixteen seventeen two hundred thousand
pounds seventeen eighteen 425 thousand
pounds
without work on this option 3-3 freezing
nights cold weather protocol before we
offer accommodation to become their
worry of course the one not German can
can we have some reassurance that before
winter comes before winter comes we
would have reexamined our cold-weather
protocol because I clearly also effects
the bed-and-breakfast figures Thank You
counselor Albany um thank you Jim I just
wanted to make a comment with regard to
the mysterious situation of how it could
be 170 overspent now and ending up 150
members will recall that Universal
Credit was bought in and that meant that
it was increasingly difficult for the
council to actually get housing benefit
payments for bed-and-breakfast
accommodation well that has now been
changed it's been reinstated or rather
Housing Benefit has been reinstated for
baby
so the we won't get the irrecoverable
irrecoverable benefits back which was
some 62,000 but we will be able to get
benefits payments with it being
reintroduced
7,000 underspend comes for pension think
thank you leader and just to give you
the absolute reassurance this is not the
sound of something being kicked out that
I can being kicked down the road this is
the sound of us actually looking to make
the right choice and the right decision
if you if you take a look at the report
you'll see that if you look at point 1
point 3 the work that we've done around
securing temporary accommodation from
orbit and other landlords as targeted
single people when you look at one point
six
you know we've got four client groups
and actually it's the single people that
client group is that is the target group
and we do need to see the outcome of the
work that we've been doing and that's
only been running for a couple of months
or so we need to do we need to actually
be in a position where we put the right
type of accommodation in place to meet
the medium and long short medium and
long term need rather than just jump
straight away so you can have my
absolute assurance and this was part of
the discussion with offices that we are
going to be coming back and in the early
financial year we will have come to a
conclusion as to what is the best
solution so this is not just saying and
then we'll start doing the work so this
is not being part we're looking at the
situation we're looking at what we need
to be doing so that by the time we get
to the new financial year we've got a
robust evidence base to come back with a
proper decision making process around
the most appropriate temporary
accommodation solution and you can have
my absolute assurance that that's that's
what's intended here and that's and you
can hold me to that because you will
going to be included in next year's
budget chairman but does anyone know
anything about the cold weather protocol
Germany for cap yes just weeks we're
fully aware of the commitment to review
the cold-weather protocol and we plan to
do it before the cold weather returns
German if that's of any comfort can I
just be clear mr. weeks if that is
reviewed does a paper have to come to
cabinet so a paper will be coming to
cabinet before the onset of winter
comfortable councillor Morse thank you
so if we look at the recommendation on
page 49 our cabinet happy with that
recommendation a grade grade in that
case we will thank you for that cabinet
we will move on to agenda item 11 which
is delivering local needs local choice
rural housing and this is a game
councillor Pemberton Thank You chair it
is indeed one of those afternoons so so
the report before you looks at the work
of our rural housing enabler looking at
community lead and local needs schemes
and this analysis takes us up to the end
of July and really what we're seeking
here is an endorsement of the approach
that we have as Renata and Sara have
been working on for some while to focus
on those communities where we've yet to
get high-level engagement so I sort of
rag indicator red amber green approaches
taken so that when you look at the
report we're focusing firstly on
converting those amber communities
I've to a green classification and
that's to say to have a scheme that we
can get up and and and delivering on
make further attempts to engage the the
red communities where there are funding
streams available particularly through
section 106 and ensure that those who
are actually in the in the green that
those those communities continue to make
the progress that we have we have we
have outlined and we anticipate so
really this is a sort of an endorsement
of the approach and a check-in in terms
of the work that the team have been
doing so any questions I'll bring them
on the detail but other than that and
members looking for agreement to the
recommendation in the report just
recalled you just briefly councillor
Pemberton I noticed a number of the
communities and one or two in my patch
as it so happens I didn't appreciate
this there's no progress at all and it's
as if they're unwilling to even accept
that there is a need what's happening
about those particular communities and
asking them to go out and find out if
there's a need perhaps if I might ask
Renard you want to perhaps it help
councillor cargo with a with the kind of
engagement we've got with some of these
communities to say genuinely I mean
serve the contacts all communities and
nearly at least to actually see whether
they want to do something I mean there's
all sorts of reasons why some
communities that want to do which she
listed but in the end it's their choice
are you thinking of anything in
particular no
I think in the report
we fought somewhere at the bottom of
page 64 24.1 we have listed some of the
reasons one of the biggest is actual
sort of fear you know what it might
commit them to and that's partly a
legacy of when we had all the appeals
before the core strategy came into place
generally the thought scheme so
themselves that when you get something
done the neighboring parishes tend to
look at it and think we would like to do
that I mean that's the biggest advocate
ease that do it are quite proud of it
but there is a list of sort of reasons
and is vested interests I do know I do
notice that while he was saying that
there was seem to be some enthusiastic
nodding from Miss brooke-taylor
councillor Pemberton yeah I think you
know there is an element of you know
bringing a horse to water with some of
these things and where we're not in the
business of you know imposing from the
top development and I do think there is
a role for all members of of the
authority to be liaising with their
various parish councils within their own
wards to understand any barriers you
know understand any fears as well and
for us to try and identify in more
detail and try and work with them so
perhaps just thinking that it might be
timely for us to perhaps get something
out to all members you know to try and
encourage them to work with their local
communities and try and identify the
positive benefits that sort of
small-scale
developments can have for individual
communities other than that it is really
a piece of work to try and win hearts
and minds in the first instance would
that be fair enough
Thank You counselor Pemberton a good
piece of work a good paper obviously
quite a lot of progress has been made in
my congratulations on what appears to be
a job being well done recommendation on
page 57 are we happy with that cabinet
great thank you
moving up
Netaji 2015 to 2020 I would just comment
that this is a very very thorough
document councillor Pemberton Thank You
leader this is getting boring isn't it
and I would expect nothing less of
Renata and and with the previous reports
as well with Sara all of John's team do
an excellent job and cover up for my own
inefficiencies and deficiencies but now
this is a good piece of work and it is
an important piece of evidence that we
have to keep up-to-date to inform our
housing strategy and really what we're
looking for is another you know for
cabinet's confirmation to adopt the
evidence log if any member has any
particular questions or points to raise
then that between us I'll be looking at
Renata we can take them off other than
that looking for support for the
recommendation Thank You councillor
Pemberton before we move straight onto
this there was one or two I found very
interesting comments in the evidence log
some of them were really quite
frightening one of the comments was that
some people want food bank vouchers so
that they can spend money on other
things and I think the other things
could well include drugs I mean that is
a rather chilling statement and there
was also statement made somewhere that
if people have provided with food and
clothing it actually gives them more
money to spend
presumably on drugs they
sorry I think it is unlikely it could be
electricity or water if they're in
supported accommodation councillor Morse
but nice try the other thing is
obviously the reference information on
the price of houses and the ratio of
means to house prices is important the
one point I have already picked up and
queried is the population growth I have
been referred reassured that the numbers
in it are as Office of National
Statistics but I think it will be well
worth keeping an eye on those because
frankly I think they seem a little low
but with that I would actually commend
this as a excellent piece of work so
with that the recommendation sorry
councillor Pemberton sorry I think I
would just make an observation Peter I
think the challenge for all of us
whether we are confronted with people
who find themselves forced to access
food banks or people who present on the
streets as beggars is the best solution
to support that person if you take you
know somebody on the street throwing
that cash in there in the cap the
proverbial cab isn't necessarily the
right thing to do equally we have to
recognize that there are people who are
vulnerable and who you know we have to
guard against the law of unintended
consequences where we provide vouchers
for food and that enables something else
so it is a complex issue and it's you
know you know it's not you know we're
not sort of you know in the in this in
the game we're saying you know that you
know that you know I take your point but
you know we have got it you know we have
got to understand that those are things
that are actually happening and we need
to find a ways of doing it I apologize I
just wanted just to make that that Thank
You councillor Pemberton I
would endorse what you said about the
law of unintended consequences sometimes
applying with that the recommendation
that the evidence log 2018 for the
housing strategy 2015 2020 be adopted is
cabinet in agreement great thank you
moving on to item 13 disposal disposal
of the grange saw them councillor organ
thank you chairman the grange at south
and was formerly an area office for the
council since it closed it has been let
out to various organizations however
it's now mainly unoccupied it's a grade
2 listed building and requires
considerable maintenance much time an
effort has been spent considering
various options for the future of the
building including conversion to
apartments letting the building either
entirely or as office suites and selling
the building either with its grounds or
without a venture house model was also
considered unfortunately this failed to
gain growth hub support in conclusion to
considered best for the future of the
listed building and surroundings to sell
the building with a small curtilage so
that the majority of the grounds and the
peace garden are retained this report
seeks authorization for the head of
technical and community services to
dispose of the grange in consultation
with the leader and portfolio holder for
resources and property
thank you councillor house could I just
ask cantor organ if the proceeds of the
sale will be used to support other
things in it is generally not the
council's policy to bring face fence
funds from the sound of one thing
indirectly into that community it's
generally the policy that funds that
wash into the council all go into the
capital budget and every year there are
bids for various and capital projects
that are assessed and ranked according
to their priorities
in the entire community and funding
therefore goes out to those projects so
funding that comes in from one area can
be spent on another area and the other
way around if I may interject there I
think we do have thoughts on actually
investing money in saw them the question
at the moment is identifying the best
way of doing it
councillor kettle I note are the two
Ward numbers comments that there in
support of changed the Grange the only
point I would make from a broader point
of view was sarvam is the first is the
furthest main rural center from
Stratford town there have been comments
made that until recently they hadn't
been a chairman coming from anywhere
east of the m-40 in living history and
that actually whilst there was a huge
commercial logic in having a rational
solution to the Grange it is a pity that
Stratford is watch Michael was drawing
over the m-40 back to here and a lot of
residents find Stratford very remote
from from Southam and other villages
further east and therefore if there is
any spare is you following up council
crumbs comments the investment of the
proceeds can be directly identified as
being put back into south and rather
than available along with other seeds
that would be I think very helpful and I
know we live in a digital age and
everything is available online but there
are still significant numbers of people
particularly in the east of the district
who are not that familiar with been on
the digital age who actually a property
is quite key
just wishes Parish Council you just have
an office inside of them and has moved
it into this last fortnight which has
been welcomed hugely by residents
because they don't have access a lot of
them don't have access the internet and
having a okay
it's the third tier local authority
rather second tier having a local
authority office in the settlement has
been incredibly popular and I think we
need to ensure the residents have
reassured no services have been
withdrawn a very long time ago but
actually the physical presence that
there is some effort to reflect
residence in East District Council in
Pemberton thank thank you leader and
chairman just to give you some
reassurance the to ward members for
precise 'litham have recently written to
me with what I might call a shopping
list of of issues and obviously wanting
to tap into access to various funds that
may be available arising out of out of
development so there's a dialogue to be
had there about identifying priorities
so I think again to give the assurance
that you know that as far as this this
cabinet is concerned that it's a cabinet
for the whole of the district not just
the sort of West if you will and
certainly I'll be picking up with the
the ward members on their aspirations
and undoubtedly that will feed through
into further discussions perhaps with
with south and tang council itself so
absolutely looking for ways to ensure
that all our residents not only not only
feel supported but are supported just to
point out that thousand has had this new
library complex recently which sorry
a bit closer okay there has been the new
library development in Salem which is a
bonus to the community it has a new cat
terminal in in Salem as well and of
course there were the three community
rooms in the library development that
the town council were going to have but
for whatever reason couldn't so the
district council did step in and take
those in order to preserve them for the
community and there are fans all the
time being spent in areas of the
district and I just have to think of one
that I can think of right at this moment
where the new boiler is required for the
throwing pool and that's in the region
of some 75,000 pounds so it's not an
inconsiderable sum so money is still
being spent in Salem as we speak as
indeed it does in other areas and there
are I think the reasons for having a
central pot is because sometimes these
monies have to be spent quickly I think
the point that you made councilor cattle
were well made we certainly have not
forgotten sell them we do our best not
to forget any part of the district
because it is a district as a whole the
issue is that sometimes we are not
wholly in control of our own priorities
when things come whizzing out of the
woodwork at us nevertheless we have some
thoughts about Southen and the potential
for actually invested in it at the
moment there needs to be more clarity on
exactly what will be best but rest
assured it is not forgotten
so with that unless there are any more
questions or discussion our council
happy with the recommendation and can I
have your agreement of otherwise please
raid thank you next item on the agenda
revenue budget monitoring councilor
organ Thank You chairman
this report covers the period to the
31st of July and forecast an unfavorable
out turn for the financial year of forty
three thousand four hundred pounds
details of main budget variances to date
are included within paragraph three and
the forecast out turn is in paragraph
four the biggest unfavorable variance
which has already been alluded to
earlier in the meeting is a hundred and
fifty thousand in housing and that
relates mainly to additional expenditure
on temporary accommodation and
bed-and-breakfast accommodation in
addition to this the estimated
additional costs have taken credit card
payments following the abolition of
surcharges on such transactions is
forecast to be seventy thousand pounds
for which there is no budget the
continuance and implications of taking
payments by credit card will require
consideration and it is appropriate that
a further report is bought hopefully to
the next cabinet and the recommendation
is that the revenue budget monitoring is
received and that a report on the future
of credit card payments is brought to
the October cabinet
thank you organ councilor kettle mr.
chairman as you know I spoke to you
briefly earlier on this morning may I
firstly thank mr. Buckland for Appendix
two to item 14 which is important
addendum to Appendix 1 and the reason I
say that is as you know I am a
bean-counter
not necessary at heart but that is my
professional qualification and the
picture when you're counting beans very
much depends which pot you put the beans
in and if you look through Appendix one
there is no significant seriously large
variance over the one that counts the
organs referred to there are variances
positive and variance a negative 19,000
18,000
11,000 32,000 all of which commendably
within the overall budget and it nets
off to 41,000 which out of a spend of 6
million is not a huge variance
however as those of you who sat on we
with the OECD which mr. chairman you did
we did look at an alternative way of
looking at these numbers and that is
spending by category rather than by
service and when we look at that and we
look down 1 2 3 4 5 we see that the
overspend on third-party payments is
actually 545,000 mr. Buckland did
explain where that came from and it
relates to an early issue housing
housing support temporary housing
acceptor et cetera but I think what is
really worrying is if we cut the
categories listed on appendix 2 among
all the different service heads it looks
quite a reasonable picture in Appendix 1
but when we look at the overall spend to
be spending half a million more than
budget on third-party payments and
100,000 and supplies and service
expenses that those figures are very big
figures firstly I would like to
recommend that this analysis has
continued but I think it's important
that we should have a commentary on
Appendix 2 as much as Appendix 1 because
what it is doing it is pulling pulling
through as I'm sure most about them will
confirm the third-party payments in each
different section and if we cut them up
into each different section the variance
is not as visible and therefore may we
may we will continue this but I think it
would be worthwhile having commentary on
that very significant variance thank you
come to the kettle wood counselor organ
or mr. Buckland care to comment please
I'm more than happy to provide a
commentary on some of them more
significant so I must speak up Chris
yeah I'm more than happy to provide a
commentary on some of the more
significant variances on the subjects of
analysis on appendix - absolutely and of
course when we produce the budget papers
which will be coming forward in January
and February we do did give that
analysis for each of the service heads
which is shown on appendix one so you'll
be able to see there the variance within
that as well so absolutely no problem
with that I think your commentary would
be on that will be welcome it's always
better to have a very thorough analysis
looked at looking at things in different
ways than it is to have a single line so
thank you for that so any more questions
or debate in that case turning to the
recommendations on page 85 or cabinet
happy with the recommendations on page
85 a report to the October cabinet
members of cabinet happy to have a
report to the October cabinet on the
issuing point to thank you members of
cabinet so we now move on to the we now
move on to the work plan the work plan
is being circulated and presumably we
will need to add the item this has been
agreed fine people happy with the work
plan thank you and now to the on block
items and I believe council Morse you
have a query on the minutes from the
strategic policy advisory group
concerning trees
yes sir I could ask if you've kind of
greed to arrange the spag this policy a
bunch of group minutes and particularly
the tree management protocol I have here
chairman I would just briefly say about
the tone of the document before I move
on but I get the impression reading that
that if you touch a council tree you're
more likely to have your own limbs cut
off and the trees there are nine
separate threats each other which we any
unauthorized work to a tree may result
in prosecution or civil action that's
repeated nine times I think once would
be enough chairmen to to get the point
across but anyway German leads five
minutes a following consideration it was
agreed that the protocol should be
approved following an informal
consultation battalion parish councils
several points a German our Council is
not to be consulted with consulting
parish in town but but not councillors
on this council secondly I was not aware
that the policy Advisory Group and I
think the secrets in they have the
ability to make policy and surely
accepting this agreeing this protocol
and accepting that is making policy for
the council third point chairman there
is no mention in here of land that
nobody owns or nobody claims and I have
two cases in my ward where we've got
trees on vacant land which nobody is the
named ownership claims to intruding on
residence properties I would have liked
to see something addressed in there on
that point and my final point more
general one the policy advisor group
papers I never circulated as far as I
can see and they're not available to the
public I just wondered if there was a
reason for that and I accept certainly
in policy making clearly there are some
things you want to keep confidential I
will understand that
to make the backing papers for this mr.
Grafton
can you comment on some of those points
please yes comment on the policy point
and also the safest point so I'm the
policy point I quite agree the answers
in the name of the group really isn't it
it's an advisory group so it's there to
advise the cabinet on policy so I would
expect once that consultation has been
carried out for a report to come to the
cabinet to approve that policy in
respect of papers and circulation
certainly since I've been here I don't
think we've actually published actively
proactively published reports the reason
for that is because it's not a
decision-making group if it were a
decision-making group then it would be
subject to the publication requirements
under the 1972 local government act like
cabinet like council like council
committees but non decision-making
bodies in accounts are different they're
not they're not subject to the
legislation they're not even within the
Constitution and what we've done
traditionally although we haven't
actively published we have made
available under foi documents if they're
asked for except for some of the papers
which would be on blue or in other words
they'd be confidential for which subject
to exemptions applying we generally
wouldn't provide on a freedom of
information request so that's why we
handle it and that's the reasoning
behind it
fairly lengthy discussion on policy
making and frankly the lack of advice
from the everywhere scrutiny group on
policymaking then the policy papers
behind this I welcome the fact that the
policy will now come forward to the
cabinet for decision Thank You
councillor Morris I also note the point
that councillors should be consulted on
the tree policy I think that can easily
be done I am well aware of the changes
that been proposed to OSC and it will be
how the relationship between what is
discussed at OSC and what is discussed
at strategic policy advisory group
actually emerges over time the other
thing I would just say is as you are
aware your colleague councillor right is
actually on the strategic policy
advisory group excellent because I have
been its policy advisory groups where
almost the entire papers are on blue so
thank you for that councillor Morse and
the policy will come to cabinet after
its being consulted on
no no urgent business chairman closed